Because accessibility is so
broad and the usership is so
diverse, we're going to need
a roadmap to guide us on our journey.
Throughout this course we'll
be referring to WCAG, or
the Web Content Accessibility Guidelines
2.0.
WCAG is a set of guidelines and best
practices which have been put together
by accessibility experts to try and
answer the question of what
accessibility means in a methodical way.
Several countries actually mandate
the use of these guidelines
in their web accessibility
legal requirements.
WCAG is organized around
four core principles.
The first is making sure
users can perceive content.
This helps us keep in mind that just
because something is perceivable with
one sense such as sight, that doesn't
mean that all users can perceive it.
Second, is it operable can users use
UI components and navigate the content.
For example something which requires a
hover interaction cannot be operated by
someone who can't use a mouse or
is using a touchscreen.
Third, can users understand the content?
Also, can all users
understand the interface and
is it consistent enough
to avoid confusion?
And finally, is it robust enough for
the content to be consumed by
a wide variety of user agents?
And does it work with
assistive technology?
Together this forms POUR.
While WCAG provides an extremely
comprehensive set of guidelines to help
us keep many facets of accessibility in
mind, it can also be a bit overwhelming.
To help mitigate this, the Web aim group
has distilled the WCAG guidelines down
into an easy to follow checklist,
targeted specifically for web content.
The webbing checklist can give you
a short high level summary of what you
need to implement while also
linking to the underlying or
tag specifications if you
need an expanded definition.
Both WCAG and the checklist cover
a lot of the accessibility space.
The guidelines can only
ever be a limited proxy for
actual accessibility what actually
matters is the user experience.
I'm just checking some box.
So while these guidelines
give us a framework for
thinking about accessibility, there may
be places where they're incomplete or
even give advice which
is a little out of date.
However, they're still
an excellent resource for
helping us integrate
accessibility into our process.
With these tools in hand we can chart
a direction for our accessibility work,
be confident that so long as our project
is meeting the outlined criteria,
our users should have
a positive experience.